[Música]
cuanto importante es el trabajo en
nuestras vidas para que vamos a trabajar
para poder vivir cierto pero y si el
trabajo no nos hace felices
si esto es así podemos decir que vivimos
únicamente para el fin de semana o para
las vacaciones cuantificamos
vivimos de una forma plena dos de cada
siete días un mes de cada doce es decir
120 días de los 365 días del año solo
aprovechamos para vivir plenamente el 33
por ciento de nuestro tiempo así nuestra
vida real se reducirá a unos 25 años
quizás sólo 19
entonces si queremos vivir con plenitud
no deberíamos cambiar la perspectiva con
la que sentimos nuestros deberes
laborales o acaso solo se pueden sentir
con una vida plena algunos pocos
afortunados para quienes su trabajo le
resulta especialmente agradable y si es
así cuáles son esos trabajos que hacen
felices a las personas los que aportan
grandes salarios y estabilidad laboral
muchas de estas personas no paran de
quejarse no son felices con su trabajo
hay quien sin grandes salarios ni
estabilidad se considera afortunado
a qué se debe la existencia de estos
perfiles tan contradictorios nos hemos
pasado nuestra infancia y nuestra
juventud preparándonos para lograr un
trabajo que nos aporte posición social y
buen salario
nadie nos contó que hay algo más que el
mero salario económico nadie nos dijo
que existe otro salario el salario
emocional pero qué es el salario
emocional
etimológicamente salario es el pago en
sal que recibían los soldados romanos y
curiosamente lo emocional es la sal el
condimento esencial de nuestra vida que
son precisamente las satisfacciones no
económicas que nos aporta nuestro
trabajo
y como todas las cosas importantes no
las valoramos hasta que no las perdemos
yo tengo el mejor trabajo del mundo soy
docente universitario después de 24 años
de duro trabajo alcancé el máximo grado
profesional logré mi cátedra
tenía un buen salario económico y un
gran salario emocional tenía el poder de
diseñar programas formativos liderar
proyectos de investigación y sobre todo
el reconocimiento de compañeros y
alumnos profesionalmente lo tenía todo
pero un acontecimiento
que todo se viniera abajo
una de mis patentes fue denunciada
aquello corrió como la pólvora en el
campus nadie se paraba a saludarme
nadie comía conmigo me sentía solo me
sentía aislado despreciado
cuando iba a la barra a pedir un café
según llegaba a la barra todo el mundo
me abría paso se giraba y me daba la
espalda
dos años duró esa instrucción del caso
finalmente el auto del juez me absolvió
indicando la temeridad de la denuncia
sufrida
pero ya nada volvió a ser igual
calumnia que algo queda y lo que quedó
fue una profunda depresión con dos
sustos al volante y una baja laboral de
más de seis meses
un año más tarde fiche por otra
universidad por bastante menos dinero
pero con un renovado salario emocional
que compensaba con creces la pérdida de
poder adquisitivo
y lo mejor de todo fue aprender que gran
parte de ese salario emocional dependía
de mí mismo
hablar de salario emocional no es
únicamente hablar de motivación de
realización profesional o en definitiva
de felicidad
en los últimos 10 años el equipo de
investigación que lideró ha trabajado en
proyectos para la reducción de la
siniestralidad laboral estudiamos más de
100.000 siniestros en cada sector y
desarrollamos modelos matemáticos de
predicción de la siniestralidad estos
modelos son fiables en más de un 80%
pero hay algo que se nos escapa y esos
son las razones últimas por las que se
produce un accidente
sabemos que en un momento concreto el
trabajador pierde la concentración en la
tarea y desencadena el siniestro
a la pérdida de concentración se la
denomina comúnmente factor humano'
es el exceso de horas trabajadas lo que
nos hace perder la concentración en
nuestro trabajo los datos indican que la
mayor parte de los accidentes se
producen en las primeras horas de la
jornada del lunes
te gusta ir a trabajar los lunes por la
mañana la falta de concentración no es
debida a la fatiga física o mental sino
a un bajo interés por nuestra tarea
y esto está ligado al bajo salario
inexistente al bajo salario emocional
en españa y 19 millones de trabajadores
y fallecen 700 trabajadores en los 13
millones de accidentes producidos cada
año el 7 por ciento de los trabajadores
sufre un accidente el 47% de los
trabajadores causan al menos una baja
cada día en españa fallecen dos
trabajadores en accidente laboral
todo ello sin contar con los accidentes
yendo o volviendo del trabajo ni los
suicidios
cada día en españa se suicidan 10
personas
y fallecen tres en accidente de tráfico
qué grado de influencia tiene el salario
emocional en estas cifras
quizá no sea posible cuantificar lo pero
su influencia es indiscutible existen
multitud de estudios que indican que la
motivación que produce un aumento de
sueldo dura menos de tres meses la mayor
remuneración económica no induce a un
aumento de salario emocional más allá de
esos tres meses entonces cómo lograr la
motivación y la mayor satisfacción
personal en nuestro trabajo hay cosas
que no puedes cambiar del entorno de tu
trabajo
por ejemplo el lugar las personas las
tareas pero hay otras que sí que
dependen de nosotros y que nosotros
podemos cambiar nuestros pensamientos
nuestros enfoques nuestras ilusiones
nuestras ambiciones actuar sobre estas
variables para subir considerablemente
nuestro salario emocional
es que tal como pensamos generamos
emociones y estas crean los estados de
ánimo apropiados para sentirnos
motivados en aquello que estamos
haciendo
un mentor oriental
pequeños saltamontes nos diría que ante
la tarea más tediosa tienes dos opciones
una enojarte dos entregarte a ella
si te enojas el tiempo se ralentiza te
va a parecer eterno si te entregas el
tiempo fluye y tú vas a fluir con él
así la tarea no resultará lo más
gratificante posible y nuestro nivel de
concentración será el apropiado al final
los resultados obtenidos no harán más
que reafirmar y retroalimentar nuestro
estado inicial de ánimo
se trata por tanto de generar círculos
virtuosos partiendo de pensamientos
positivos o por el contrario caer en
círculos viciosos donde el pensamiento
negativo nos va a llevar a observar en
el trabajo un ejercicio desagradable que
hay que soportar para ganar un dinero
que nos permita sobrevivir es decir una
verdadera condena
quienes argumentan me engañarán en el
salario pero no en el trabajo
son víctimas de su propio engaño porque
negocian con su propia desmotivación
desprecian su realización profesional su
felicidad laboral su salud psíquica y
según sea la tarea que desempeñan pueden
poner en riesgo su propia integridad
física
así pues el primer acto
el primer acto preventivo de una jornada
laboral es sin duda imponerse
pensamientos positivos sobre nuestras
tareas sentir las importantes saber los
útiles tenernos autoestima
[Música]
p tú
utilidad relevancia y motivación son
partes fundamentales de un salario
emocional
[Música]
en mi caso particular horas antes de
iniciar una clase pienso en cómo de bien
voy a explicar un teorema o un proceso
físico-químico y cómo van a flipar mis
alumnos con la pizarra que les voy a
dejar al final de la clase bueno
es cierto que hay trabajos donde es muy
difícil pensar en estas claves un
esclavo en el sur de eeuu difícilmente
hubiese podido tener esta visión y hoy
hay muchos trabajos que se perciben como
una verdadera esclavitud
sin embargo hay muchos casos en los que
las personas se imponen sobre sus
dificultades por muy extremas que sean
porque a pesar de todo tú decides sobre
tu actitud y sobre la perspectiva de tu
vida
la felicidad está en nuestro modo de
mirar la vida y de aceptar y enfrentar
las adversidades
sólo con que imagines un futuro mejor ya
estás trabajando para lograr ese futuro
mejor
esto es inalienable
si finalmente tu trabajo no te aporta el
salario emocional que deseas tendrás que
descubrir que quieres y esforzarte para
lograrlo busca otro lugar o trabaja por
cuenta propia el precio
salir de tu zona de confort y adquirir
nuevas habilidades
la recompensa vivir plenamente siempre
hay tiempo de mejorar
por ardua y pesada que sea nuestra tarea
miremos el lado positivo y el lado
motivador de la misma
quizá esta recomendación no solo vaya a
hacernos más felices en nuestra vida
quizá esta recomendación pueda
salvaguardar nuestra salud e incluso
nuestra vida
[Música]
[Aplausos]